hello everyone so i'm talking about how
to find the tangent plane to a graph and
i think the first step of that is to
just figure out how we control planes in
three dimensions in the first place so
what i have pictured here is a red dot
representing a point in three dimensions
and the coordinates of that point easily
enough
are
3. so the x coordinate is 1 the y
coordinate is 2 and the z coordinate is
3. and then i have a plane that passes
through it and the goal of the video is
going to be to find a function a
function that i'll call l that takes in
a two-dimensional input
x and y and this function l should have
this plane as its graph
now the first thing to notice is that
there's lots of different planes that
could be passing through this point
right at the moment it's one that's got
a certain kind of angle you could think
of it going up in one direction but you
could give this a lot of different
directions and get a lot of different
planes that all pass through that one
point so we're going to need to find
some way of distinguishing the specific
one that we're looking at which is this
one right here from other possible
planes that can pass through it and as
we work through you'll see you'll see
how this is done in terms of partial
derivatives
but as we are getting our head around
what the formula for this graph can be
let's just start observing properties
that it has the first property is that
the graph actually passes through this
point one two three and what that means
in terms of you know functions over here
is that if you evaluate it at the point
one two the input pair where both where
x is one and y is two then it should
equal three it should equal three
because that's telling you that when you
go to x equals one and y equals two and
then you say what's the height of the
graph above that point it should be the
the z coordinate of the desired point so
this right here is kind of fact number
one that we can take into consideration
and beyond that let's start thinking
about what makes planes what makes these
kind of flat graphs different from the
sort of curvy graphs that you might be
used to in other multivariable functions
the main idea is that if you intersect
it with another plane so here i'm going
to intersect it with y equals 2 this
kind of constant plane and
so i'll go ahead and write that down
that plane that you're looking at is y
equals two
and you can think of this as
representing you know what does movement
in the x direction look like as we move
along the x direction this kind of has a
slope it the two planes intersect along
a line and that's one of the crucial
features of a plane is that if you
intersect it with another plane you just
get a straight line meaning the slope is
constant as you move in the x direction
but it's also constant that same slope
if you move in the y direction if i had
chosen a different plane you know if
instead i had chosen y equals 1 which
looks like this
then you get a line with the same slope
and no matter what constant value of y
you choose it's always intersecting that
plane with a line that has the same
slope
and now if you look back to the videos
on partial derivatives and in particular
on how you interpret the partial
derivative of a function with respect to
its graph
what this is telling you is that when we
take the partial derivative
of l with respect to x because constant
y means you're moving in the x direction
this should just be some kind of
constant some kind of constant a i'll
kind of emphasize that as a
constant value here
and the same the same goes in the other
direction right let's say instead of
intersecting it with constant values of
y you say well what if you intersected
it with a constant value of x like x
equals one well in that case what you
should get because you're intersecting
it with a plane is another straight line
so these two planes are intersecting
along a straight line which means as you
move in the y direction this slope won't
change but also as you move in the x
direction if you imagine slicing it with
a bunch of different planes all
representing different constant values
of x you would be getting a line with
that same slope and that's telling you
another powerful fact that the partial
derivative of l with respect to y you
know if you're moving in the y direction
that's equal to some other constant that
i'm going to call b
and now keep in mind these are very
these are very powerful statements
because the partial derivative of l with
respect to x is a function this is a
function of x and y and that might
actually be worth emphasizing here that
this partial derivative of x with
respect to y is something that you
evaluate at
you know a point in two-dimensional
space and we're saying that that's equal
to some kind of constant value now
that's a pretty powerful thing right
because it's telling you it's giving you
control over the function at all
possible input points you know for
movement in a specified direction and
the same goes over here this is this is
telling you that um a function is
constantly equal to you know some value
b and we're not sure what this value b
is uh but just geometrically we can kind
of estimate what these things should be
so if i take back uh the plane
representing a constant y value and we
say what's this slope you know you're
moving in the x direction we've got a
constant y value what is the slope at
which this plane intersects our graph i
would estimate this as about a slope of
two you know you kind of go over one and
it goes up two so what that would tell
you is that at least in the in the
specific graph that we're looking at
this is at least approximately equal to
2.
and then similarly if we look at a
constant constant x value
and we say that represents movement in
the y direction
what is the slope there
this this looks to me like about one as
a slope you kind of move over one unit
you go up one unit so i'd say down here
that the constant value of the partial
derivative with respect to y is about
equal to one
so we have three different facts here
the value of the function at the point 1
2 the value of its partial derivative
with respect to x everywhere and the
partial derivative with respect to y
everywhere
and this information is actually going
to be enough to tell us what the
function as a whole should equal
now specifically
this idea that the partial derivative
with respect to x is constant tells us
that the function
function l of x y
is going to equal
2 times x
plus something that doesn't have any x's
in it something that as far as x
concerned is a constant because the only
thing whose derivative with respect to x
is the constant 2 is 2x plus something
that's constant as far as x is concerned
and then similarly over here if the
partial with respect to y is the
constant 1 then that tells you that the
whole function looks like
you know this looks like a constant as
far as y is concerned so once we once we
bring in y it's going to be 1
times y
plus something that's constant as far as
y is concerned you know this part is
already constant as far as y is
concerned so anything that i add beyond
here has to be constant as far as both x
and y is concerned so that part has to
actually literally be a constant so i'm
just going to put in i'm just going to
put in c for that
to represent constant
so this is you can see this is a very
restrictive property on our function
because the only place x can show up is
as this linear term and the only place y
can show up is as this linear term and
when i use the word linear you can
pretty much interpret it as saying the
the term x shows up without an exponent
or without anything fancy happening to
it it's just x times a constant that's
pretty much what i mean by linear it's
got more precise formulations in other
contexts but as far as we're concerned
here you can just think of it as meaning
variable times a constant
so the question is what should this c be
and you can imagine that we can based on
this property based on the value at the
point 1 2 we can uniquely determine c
and you can plug in x equals 1 y equals
know that this has to equal 3 and solve
for c
which we could do but i'm going to
actually do something a little bit more
convenient i'm going to kind of shift
around where the constants show up and
i'm going to say that the whole function
should equal
2 times and then i'm going to put a
constant in with x i'm going to say x
minus
1.
and then i'm going to do the same thing
with y i'm going to say plus 1 here's
the partial derivative with respect to y
y minus and then i'm going to say 2.
and the reason i'm doing this notice
this doesn't take change the partial
derivative information it's just if we
take the partial derivative with respect
to x this will still be 2 and when we
take it with respect to y this will
still be 1. but the reason i'm putting
these in here is because we're going to
evaluate it at the point 1 2 so i want
to make it look as easy as possible to
evaluate at the point 1 2
and then from here i'm just going to add
another constant
so instead of saying c because this is
going to be slightly different from c
i'll call it k but the idea is i'm just
moving around constants if you imagine
distributing the multiplication here and
having you know 2 times that negative 1
and 1 times that negative 2 you're just
changing what the value of the constant
stuck on the end here is now the
important part the reason that i'm
writing it this way which is only
slightly different is because then when
i evaluate this at l
of 1
this whole first part cancels out
because plugging in x equals 1 means
this whole part goes to 0.
same with the second part because when i
plug in y equals 2 this part goes to 0.
so k this other constant that i'm
tagging on the end is going to
completely specify what what happens
when i evaluate this at the point one
two and of course i want it to be the
case that when i evaluate it at one two
i get three
i want it to be the case when i evaluate
it one two i get three so that tells me
that this constant k here
should just equal
three
so notice the way the way that i've
written the function here is actually
quite powerful we have a lot of control
this term 2 was telling us the slope
with respect to x so when you move
purely in the x direction and that was
kind of illustrated here purely in the x
direction that's telling us the slope
with respect to x and then this term one
here was telling us the slope with
respect to y so when we moved purely in
the y direction that's telling us the
slope there and we could just turn those
knobs if we change the two and we change
the one that's what's going to allow us
to basically change what the slopes of
the plane are i'm going to say slopes
plural because it's with respect to the
x and the y direction and that'll give
us control over various different planes
that pass through you know if i'm
looking at the one oh geez i don't let's
say the one right here um
then the movement in the y direction is
very shallow so that would be turning
this knob lower and instead of one it
might be point zero one and if i were
looking at movement in the x direction
you know this looks actually negative so
this would tell you that it's going to
be some kind of negative number so you
can kind of dial these knobs and that
changes the different
planes that pass through that same point
and then plugging in this one two and
three tells us what point we're
specifying but we're basically saying
when you input x equals one and you
input y equals 2 the whole thing should
equal 3. so this form right here is is
powerful enough that i i want you to
remember it for the next video i want
you to remember the idea of writing
things down in this way where you
specify the point it's passing through
with its x coordinate y coordinate and z
coordinate placed where they are and
then you tweak the slopes using these
coefficients out front so with that i
will see you next video